China is rolling out the red carpet for
political and financial leaders from
more than 50 countries around the world
it's the first time the boa forum is
taking place entirely in person since
the start of the covid-19 outbreak for
China's new Premiere it's also his first
address to an international audience
since being appointed as the country's
second in command
we need to adhere to a common and
comprehensive cooperation and
sustainable security concept oppose the
abuse of unilateral sanctions and
long-armed jurisdiction oppose the
selection of science at group
confrontation and the new Cold War
this event is often billed as Asia's
version of the world economic forum and
although discussions center around major
Global issues China's message this year
is focused closer to home right now with
the political tensions trade tensions
military tensions that are going on not
just over Ukraine but between China and
the US you're going to see China trying
to reach out
especially to asean because these are
countries that China has a very good
trade with
analysts expect China to use the Forum
to promote Asia as an investment Safe
Haven at a time of global economic
volatility China is talking up its own
economic recovery prospects after the
end of its long-running strict covid-19
rules Chinese premier league is
promising that China's own rebound can
power a post-pandemic bounce back for
the rest of the world
economists are forecasting Chinese
growth as high as 5.8 percent this year
that's up from three percent last year
one of its weakest growth rates in
decades many foreign businesses remain
cautious about doing business in China
as a result of major supply chain
disruptions brought on by covid-19
restrictions and Regulatory crackdowns
on the private sector
there is a strong message there will be
a strong reinforcement of the state
sector playing a pillaring role within
the Chinese economy and that's in a way
a discontinuation from the Bola message
that was uh very much about economic
reforms uh private sector growth uh in
the past the decade prior to the
pandemic and so now there is a certainly
a pivot there
China wants to spark a pivot towards
Global collaboration too political
leaders from Malaysia Singapore and
Ivory Coast have echoed that call with
their opening speeches at the boa forum
analysts say the next challenge for
China is to convince the world that it
should be the coordinating Center of
that Global cooperation effort Richard
Kimber Al Jazeera Hong Kong